will be telling us about craft
convergence and epidemic
thank you
[Music]
before starting my talk just a short
personal story in 2017 was the first
time in summer that i learned was
simon's institute it was
before the
senior year of my undergrad and back
then i watched these like cool youtube
videos and i was like oh my god will i
be ever
able to visit this
like circular editorial in person then
like in 2019 i visited here for
geometric polynomials and i was super
excited back then and now you can tell
how excited i am to give the talk here
for the cool audience here
uh yes so i'm jaganna i'm a phd student
at stanford and um so so far in the pa
in the talks of the boot camp we learned
about
graph convergence and epidemics also
percolation and i try to like
marry them together and see what we can
learn if we put things together
so as in the previous talks we are
considering spread of infection over the
networks and the main question you're
asking is that what information about
this underlying network of people do we
need
to predict something about the epidemics
and
kind of so far we have learned
many model dependent answers and what do
i mean by that is that
let's say they have
a network of like we are like a studying
a city there is some underlying network
the first step would be for example to
find the right model to like
uh model that network and we have seen
many different things starting from
earth training which kind of like is
modeling a homogeneous mixing of people
but then there is a problem that like
you you don't have like super spreaders
there you don't like uh
differentiating different type of people
and then we saw a configuration model
that like
sue uh
talk about it a lot and then uh
again they're like uh
then it doesn't have a dynamic nature
and preferential attachment was kind of
introduced to uh introduce those like
dynamics and then there was like a
stochastic block model to like see
to characterize different types of
people that are coming from different
backgrounds but then like with all the
sparse model before
uh there was a problem of like
these models aren't like really
creating many cycles which is not really
realistic in real networks so later
there were like models which we haven't
yet seen
called household models
that introduce cycles on top of for
example configuration
model
and preferential attachment
but then just just the the point is that
like there are so many models
i first have to choose one of them and
then after i choose that then i have to
estimate relevant parameters so that's
another step up like adding noise and
like making the problem hard so for
example for earth training i need to
estimate the average degree or like for
configuration model i need to estimate
the degree sequence
but the main question i'm asking here is
that can we have a model-free estimation
of epidemics of different cooperatives
of epidemics
so what do i mean by different
properties of epidemics
in these different models as we all saw
there are like some
characteristics that are the same in uh
qualitative we know also so for example
we have like some phase transition
so
in erdogan your configuration model if i
start from probably p of like
transmission everybody is isolated there
is no outfit and as i increase the p
finally i get to kind of like a complete
graph and there is like a whole
transmission there is a point that like
there was like kind of a phase
transition that this kind of science
stuff
and um
can we see that like in more general
graphs without like i saw the model
there is also about
another property that
we see in many random graph models is
like the uniqueness of the giant or the
uniqueness of the output
also like maybe more sophisticated is to
see whether the size of this giant
component converges or not because
that's like
maybe more difficult questions like can
i like
see the time transition of epidemics can
i like find super spreaders in the
network
but
today i'm going to mainly focus on like
these three properties
and i'm asking again that like without
assuming the underlying model or like
really discovering the whole network
because that's impossible or also
like
computationally hard
can i say something about epidemics can
i find a metatherapy connecting these
different properties for all the graph
models that we have seen
with that let's let me
formalize the epidemic process that we
are seeing we consider a very simple
epidemic model to answer like that last
question
we have a network nodes are individuals
edges are possible in traction initially
one of these nodes is infected
in red and
that node tries
independently to infect all of its
neighbor with probability p
so it draws coin
for each neighbor and then it recovers
energy immune to the physics so this
happens again and again
until everybody every infected person
has tried this chance like in fact these
neighbors
we saw that this is equivalent to sir we
deterministic
recovery time
and
also like subic talks about the direct
like it's a relation with percolation so
in percolation you initially draw each
edge with probably p
and if you want to think of the patient
zero you are just drawing uniform random
after like you have drawn the edges
another
version of percolation that we are going
to talk about it today who is directed
percolation so initially i have again my
undirected network for each edge i
replace it with like two directed
versions i to j and j to i
and i drop each of the possible
direction independently with probability
p
so as a result maybe i have like some of
these like edges bi-directional some of
them are completely like dropped or like
somewhere it's just one way
any question about the model
complete the graph and then draw the
edges pairwise or we start with a fixed
graph structure it's just with the fixed
type it doesn't need to be country
i will tell you what do i need about the
graph but this champion
at this moment
so what i'm going to talk about today in
a nutshell
under some assumption about the graph
sequence the converging graph sequence
we are going to
say that critical probability of like
this
outbreak happening converges to its
limit
the giant is unique and also its
relative size converges to its limit
but kind of
more algorithmically interesting is that
we can estimate the limits
with some local samples
and then
at the second part we're going to like
look at the directed peripolation that i
just defined
and it has the combinatorial structure
of that saying it has a bowtie structure
and also saying the critical probability
in a directed way is the same as the
undirected threshold is the same
and
the first part i'm going to like show
you three sequence of theorems to build
up the results and then for for the last
part there's going to be another theorem
so let me formalize the results first
then at the end of the talk uh i will
like go over two short proofs
let's start with the critical
probability there are different ways to
like
define the critical probability the way
that i'm going to use here
is this so like we have we have an
infinite graph
and you're like pretty cool is images
starting from probably zero
and then i have like also written notes
as i increase p there is a point that
we will have like an infinite jump an
infinite component and that point would
be like defining the pc g that i have
and the theorem that uh
was like uh found by benjamin nationals
and press in 2009
showed that for
any sequence of bounded degree expanders
deterministic boundary degree expanders
are converged to a limit
the
pc of like this finite gas converges to
its limit too
so yeah like the takeaway is kind of
like
just a critical priority convince limit
that means that if we are below pc there
is
no chance of like having a giant
component in these like finite class
but if you are below above pc then with
probability one i'm going to have a
giant component
so
distribution of our internet processor
does assume that the drop is
deterministic if the infinite graph
would be random
then
the pc could depend on the reference of
the graph factor
so
all right so when there is
yeah i guess
yeah
pictorially what does the results
say is that like if we look at
on the x-axis we are increasing t the
probability of transition
from when we start from zero the
probability of having a giant is zero
then after like this pc g which depends
on the limit not on the finance sequence
then you have probably one of like
having the giant
there are two definitions in the theorem
that i'm going to just give a quick
recap first was we have converging
sequence
um
christian talk about it very nice today
but just as a recap
if you have missed the talk a
sequence of graphs has a
local convergence
if the distribution of the neighborhood
of a typical node converges
for example in this sequence that we
actually saw today too
uh let's say like we are like just
repeating this like kind of a structure
as n growth and there are two types of
nodes either blue or green the blue
nodes have like degree four they never
have the degree eight the green nodes
have degree they never have four so if
you look at the local neighborhood of
these as they grow
with probability half will be a blue
node we probably have universal
then the second definition that they had
in the theorem is expansion
um
i think yeah expansion is not really
it's it uh just morally means that like
a community is well connected
and it means that like if i want to like
disconnect a set from the rest of the
graph i have to like remove
linearly as many edges as their vertices
on the rest of the class
yeah of x minus square is the number of
edges between s and s bar as far as
vertices
of the graph minus s
why do i need expansion why
not just the graph converges is enough
this is like a simple example to show
you that like some sort of uh assuming
something about where connectors of the
community is necessary let's say we have
a four regular random graph on endnotes
on one side
and on the other side i have
four regular random graph each of size
like n but then like i have disconnected
component of them
and locally if i look at them
they both look similar because log n is
also growing but slowly with n locally
they look similar
so if i want to like just use the local
limit to say something about the
epidemic
i can't like describe both graphs
because on the left if one node is like
randomly affected by traveling to some
other city they just like
infect their like local neighborhood
like the log and neighborhood but on the
right there is a chance they get to the
whole like city
so now that
we kind of know about this phase
transition
the next question that one could ask is
like
do we know the giant is unique or not so
because maybe after this pcg i could
like have two giant component at the
same time
but
there was a result by alan benjamin
stacy before even the other reason that
i'll show you
which actually said that on possibly
random finite expanders with bounded
maximum degree then the giant is always
unique
so they didn't show that exists and they
just if it exists it's unique and then
like with the other theorem we know that
it exists and it's unique
but
still we have no idea about the size
what do i need i mean by that
let's just look at like some simulation
so we have
a set of population on grid
and i'm just simulating it two times
simulating an infection two times um
the green nodes are susceptible to the
infection
red nodes are infectious and
gray nodes are removed or recovered from
the grass so
let's say
they start independent like infection
processes
as it grows we will see like
the gray nodes are going to be like the
final
people that have been infected and
recovered and our goal is now that like
to see
can we say something about like what
proportion of people are in gray note as
you can see like in these like two
random simulations actually in defense
simulation the
number of people that are like so like
maybe this part here you remain like
susceptible but on the other side most
of them get infected so the
set of people that are getting effective
changes every time but can i say that
the number of people are getting
infected
is the kind of the same or not
and their next result is actually
saying yes to that question
so if we have a possibly random large
set expanders
with bounded average degrees so here we
don't need the bounded maximum degree
then the size of the
giant over n converges to its limit
and what is its limit is uh
we look at this so like i remember like
we have we are looking at
local convergence so it's kind of
convergence of like rooted graphs and
the limit is also rooted by o
so
this zeta p is defined by whether like
the root of the limit is in a connected
component of size infinity or not and we
take expectation over the randomness of
the limit that's like
what would be the size of the giant
relative size of the giant in the final
graph
but also like it's unique so like the
second largest component
goes to zero
the takeaway is the giant convergent
and
it's unique but there is also like a
second takeaway which is not maybe
obvious from this
but you can see with a little bit of
like work if one uniform random node is
initially infected
then the size of the outbreak is with
high probability
uh either like this c1
or it's a constant so like you don't
have like a middle ground with high
probability
so now we talked about like the critical
probability is
converging to the limits
the size of the giant is converging to
the limit but how can i really like
say something about this zlp because if
i have like a calculation i don't it's
really hard to like know something about
the limit or not
so the next part is just a simple
algorithm
to
estimate exactly
let's say we don't have the access to
the network but we are using an oracle
to learn something about it you have
this like huge population
and
that this algorithm this oracle
just draws one uniform random node
initially and assumes this uniform
random number is the patient zero
and it runs one
line of simulation locally with that
like patient zero
for example you want to see whether that
like question zero can like infect four
other people or not four is my input
so it tries out like to see if it can
like infect neighbors there is one more
infected person
now that one more restricted person
could infect another one
but that pers third person couldn't
infect anymore and like
in this like run of simulation
my infection died out with like three
infected
people so like the algorithm only would
like return zero for me and if it had
like
infected more than like four people
before that return one
so this is kind of like
a local contact tracing if we could if
you had access to uniform random samples
of the population
so what would be a simple estimator
using like this
algorithm
don't trace the effect
i assume
[Music]
and
um
as simple as the nature if i want to
like estimate like epidemics of this
algorithm would be that it would be that
you might just
query this like oracle a few times and
take the average
and in fact that simple estimator is the
right one for expanders if you saw
so for the same sequence of graph as in
the previous theorem
the average of
a constant number of queries to this
algorithm with constant k k was the
local neighborhood that they had to look
through
would be a one minus epsilon
approximation of zeta i remember that
like zeta was there
limit of these like outbreaks that i had
a relative size of the outbreak that i
had
is there any question yeah
to simulate an inflection starting from
weed it's like a bfs fashion
yeah no
yeah the simplest way to do it is to do
a vfx but maybe this
uniform random one that i drive has like
a large degree i don't have to look to
all of them
[Music]
just depending on k
right great
what does k epsilon look
depends on epsilon it depends on
i can tell you like
like it depends on like uh some
condition that like
um location is it like one over two
square and one thing
it depends on the graphics structure so
i can think
right
so now i definitely know
it's kind of an advertisement to
estimate that we need
let me go back to the first question
that i had which was like kind of
finding a method theorem for
the graph model that we have
so the previous theorems like the large
set expansion
with converging
limit
recovers many of the graph model with
uh with some like
something in the package that i didn't
like include here so it recovers
configuration model preferential
attachment in household model i will uh
so like in the configuration model we
need some more like assumption about
like the minimum degree we needed to be
larger than three and also we need some
more assumption about the tail of this
distribution
the preferential attachment it works in
a very like
for any purpose attachment that like the
incoming node degree is like greater
than two
and now what is the household model uh
let me uh
give you a pictorial way to like
describe it like we have let's say we
have like a network of
interacting households
and each of these nodes are going to be
like
um
now i want to like introduce any kind of
like motif or any kind of like cycle
whatever structure that i have in each
of these nodes
i would like replace each node i will
blow it up with any
connected network that i want
just i i need that like the distribution
over this connective network converges
so i have like locally converges in some
way
then
if this external graph that i have
is a large set expander with converging
limit then like after blowing up it
would be also like
large sub expanders converging limit
which means that i can apply the theorem
that we have
and this was first introduced
on top of configuration model so like
the external graph was configuration
model and then
you know on configuration model we don't
have like cycles
so
uh
yeah they wanted to like introduce like
these short cycles in the graph
but now with these like
results you can like put it on
even on top of either a preferential
attachment or any model that you want
that has
some sort of rare connections
in it
and i haven't in defined exactly what is
the largest expander i will do it
later when i'm doing the proof
but it's just a weaker version of
expander that i've showed you already
now i want to move to the
directed percolation don't read the
theorem i will go through it
um
remember again i was replacing each edge
with like
two direction and keeping each direction
with probability p
then we are like in a combinatorial
structure that you would like
you would be interested in a directed
graph one of them would be like strong
you're looking at a strongly connected
component
which is a directed graph where every
pair of nodes have like two-way
directive paths between them
we show that if we do this directed
percolation on top of
um
large set expanders
then
first the existence the
critical probability of emergence of
this like large strongly connected
component is the same as the undirected
percolation having a giant component
and second you can
now look at this like a strongly
connected component in the media and
look at the nodes that coming out of it
like in the red or look at the notes
that are like they have like a very into
it in the green
and now let's say one person in the
green or in the middle gets infected
then since like all of these middle
parts are like connected together in a
directed way then everybody in the
middle and in the red will be infected
so like what would be like the size of
an archway
morally like this middle part and the
red part
and we showed like that
relative size of this part over n
converges to the same limit as like the
giant component
uh since it's since the way that we the
percolation is symmetric between intri
in fannies and fanouts then the same
holds for the green plus the middle part
and now
as the last part is that be sure that
even node is like for example in this
green part
if you look at the out component coming
out of it before getting to the middle
then
that size is like
a little often
and if you are below the critical
pressure then like everything goes to
zero so like you have like you have just
like
a few disconnected components that are
small
that theorem that i showed you doesn't
need really expansion as long as on the
undirected percolation
you have convergence of the size and
uniqueness of the second so like the
convergence of the second component to
zero or uniqueness of the first
component then you can recover that like
bowtie structure so like there is like a
way to transition from undirected to
directed collection
so going back to the kind of the first
question that i asked
what information do i need about the
need for to say anything about
epidemics or outbreaks without knowing
the
full knowledge of the graph or knowing
the model we're kind of replacing this
full knowledge of the graph by
local information of a few samples and
we are using graph limits to like
formalize that
and
instead of knowing the model we are
assuming some global property of the
network which is expansion or like
well-connectedness of the
graph
if
there is no more question i you like go
to the proof
i have questions
in the previous slides in the classical
uh
directed rhetoric message
strongly connected component
you cannot guarantee the
upper bound right it's all about low
bound
yeah if you don't know yet like yeah
that's right it's a very general theory
because of the expansion we're
guaranteed more than one number of about
you know together
you will need yet another
yeah
yeah governing the you can't be too wild
right
now i think it's worth it i think it may
not be foreign
and then
but what would be the minimum
requirement
so that
the link soup is also
a constant factor of uh
zetas player
i don't care the exact now i i want to
have like a little bit of a
constant factor to something too much to
ask for something
yeah
i don't know the right conditions but
yeah that's a good question because we
are
as well
what is the minimum requirement that i
can
have just a little error yeah that's
that's a good one of my questions to
look at yeah
when outbreak happens
so
in principle like if you had this big
graph and you could draw the samples
from that
is there any big actually external
formulations based on the samples yeah
so like that like algorithm when i was
giving you you can
kind of like do a search on the p like
if it's like
yeah um basically what converse is lower
than like the critical probability
you can get
you maybe if you just cover them to use
array you put a uniform random variable
and then see what the picture should be
so instead of purple so i i draw my
local neighborhood
then i put beautiful diamond on it
and then if i and now i sort of i
have decided that it's this local
neighborhood which
and now i just raise my uniform until i
see 136 yeah
if i have like
access to the hundreds
not scary um
yeah that's not a good question i
actually i i don't know exactly in fact
this is how they do
um the test
and i would just like
because of something
i have another philosophical question in
case of undirected graph there is yet
another important quantity
which is
the giant is the so-called
strongly connected component is
analogous
but on the other hand the quantity that
you are showing is indeed not because uh
yeah
the
zetto p will be the different for two
quarter than the line
so
now we are going back to the first seven
but the convolution of critical
probability and we are going to see
like there are ideas behind it to the
proof when we are above the critical
probability so our goal is to prove that
like there exists a component of size
at least beta and for some beta when we
are larger than this pc
there are a few steps for that but i
think the main reason that they use this
proof is because the sprinkling
technique that they're using and it has
been used in many many papers and we
also use it ourselves like a version of
that
and what's this is frequent idea is that
like we are we are going to like um
analyze g n of p
but instead of that let's reduce the
probability p a little bit to some
problem p1 we are still above the
threshold
but not yet p
and
starting from the original graph our
first draw this like percolation on gn
of p1
and then i have a little bit of like
probability left to like add a few edges
in the future and we will see why
they're going to important and now if i
put this like
instance of gn of epsilon and gn of p1
on top of each other i have an instant
of gn of p
and
if i can say something about the two
sequence then i can say something about
the original calculation that i was
interested in
now that i have drawn like these two
instances let's first look at the
gn of p1 which was kind of like the
supercritical instance
the first step step of the proof is to
prove that
using this like local conversion to
prove that there are many components of
like size larger than some constant we
can't yet say anything about the giant
just like fix some k
that's like large enough but it's still
constant compared to n
then
with some concentration bond inequality
it's possible to show that
with high probability there are like
linear number of nodes that have a
component larger than some constant k
now the second step which is
the more interesting part in my opinion
is the sprinkling part now i have
remember i have like this
saved this like gn of epsilon before now
i put it on top of these like many
components of size k that i have and
that connects many of them together to
like create a giant component
and the second step is like to show that
there aren't any
two
large disconnected components in gn of
p1 that cannot be connected through this
like adding the gn of epsilon on top of
it
let's say i have proved like these two
steps then i can prove that there exists
a
giant component of size
linear like in n
why is that is because
you remember again like we are like
looking at the instance of g n of p one
it has many
components of size like k k is like
large constant then after i put gn of
epsilon there is no disconnected
union offsets that have like
size larger than delta n over three just
we don't care about the constant just
like some
linear size in n so that means that
there should be data and over three of
them that are totally connected after i
put this epsilon
instance on top of it
oh the small d is the maximum degree the
uniform bond and the maximum and the
function
yes
now
that we know the overall idea let me
maybe go over the detail of step two
step one and two
step one is mostly like classical so
you are going to show that um
for any constant k
there are like linear number of nodes
that are
uh
having a giant component of size k above
the critical threshold
that's
because we have a we have like a
converging sequence of expanders
and just to convert to sequences
actually enough then there exists a data
such that
in the infinite graph that i have the
uh root o connects to the k boundary
with probability larger than like
delta or like four delta
sorry
so you're now assuming that you have a
conversion sequence of expanders yes
so it's not like more restricted
and it's deterministic for public
speakers
this is because i'm above the critical
threshold and that was the definition of
critical pressure
and
now if i look at the finite graph that
is like converging to this like infinite
limit
there exists some n
such that after that a uniform random
node
would have
um would be in a giant it would be in a
component of size k with probability
like half of that let's say
and that's still not yet enough that
will only give me the bound on the
expected number of nodes with a
component larger than k
but we can get concentration bonds
because
here we are assuming the maximum degree
is bounded by some b
so if i change the status of one edge
then
i'm changing the membership of at most d
to the power k nodes in zk so like if i
change one step i only look at
i only have to look at the k
neighborhood of the two endpoints and
maybe only for those edges or those
nodes like the
giant the component of size k would
change
so i'm not changing too much i cannot
use like azuma half thing for example
and get the concentration bond that i
need
this is the first step
and what about the second step which is
now crucial using the expansion the
second step of sprinkling
for that i first need a more combinator
of the room before that's called the
mangoster
this is like not worrying about the
percolation let's just say i have
a graph g
such that for two sets of like nodes a
and b
the number of edges that i have to
remove such that this a and b are like
disconnected
let's say it's like it's some better
then the number of
pairwise edge dependent class between a
and b is also better so here if i want
to like disconnect the sets a and b i
have to definitely remove that green
edge
i have to remove one of these like
red edges and i have to remove one of
the blue edges here at
and so i need like three edges to remove
such that like a and b are disconnected
and the theorem by manga says that like
there are also three hd strong passes in
there so
the colored paths are for example
there's this
it's similar to me yeah you can because
yeah it's very similar to mean cut max
flow exactly
now i want to use menger's theorem
remember that i have fixed like some
gn of p1 and now the randomness is
coming from gn of epsilon
and
because i have expansion in my original
graph
there are many age disjoint paths
between a and b
that i haven't
i have like all sorts of randomness to
remain still on those paths
and since the average degree is bounded
i can say that
many of these
age-destroying paths must have a bounded
length otherwise
if i because there is addition if i like
count the number of edges that are in in
them like they would grow more than d
times n which is the number of edges in
the whole graph
so now i can bound the probability
that
one of these parts appear in general
first
so i can say with probability at least
epsilon to some
l which is like
bounded by a constant
each of these paths up here so the
probability that none of them up here
is actually bounded by 1 minus epsilon
to the power l to the number of paths
that i have and the number of paths is
like linear in n
so for any fixed configuration of a and
b i can
found the probability that there is no
edge disjoint path between them and
after like i realized g n of epsilon
now
i have to count how many different
configuration of a and b do i have
and
i can bound that by 2 to the power n
over k
remember like inside a and b there are
like these components of at least size k
because i'm looking at all these
components of g n of p 1 all together
so there are at most n over k of them in
the gn of p bond that i have
and the way that i can partition them
into two groups is at most like 2 to the
power n over k
now like i have
before i have bound the probability that
each of them are disjoined after like i
put this gen of epsilon on top of it i
have the number of them
so
if i multiply them that would be the
probability upper bound and the
probability that like after like i put
this gn of epsilon there is still no
path between like
some
disjoint like sets a and b
and i can bond it with like
with just like
this n times 1 over k minus some
constant which is independent of k
and now all i need
is that to choose k
large enough so that it's like this
quantity inside is negative
and the quantity inside is independent
of n so i can do that
i would have initially like used
choose k larger than like one over like
this quantity
so that would be like all the proof
steps for like sprinkling and
if there is no question i didn't go
into the like kind of a briefcase let's
point out that this is actually
a message since this is a tutorial
this
even i haven't like included all the
papers that they use is printing but it
goes back to erdog
and
so that's the original
transition gmp paper yeah exactly the
original shoe for dnp used this quickly
and it had been used like for like
looking at hamiltonians like that in
random graphics they use even in random
metrics theory in a continuous version
so that this has been reused a lot in
the
literature and there are just a little
bit different from each other each other
but the same thing which is the night
it's going back to their rush so it's a
long history behind it
and we have used it in fact for our
paper too
now let's go back to the main theorem
that we wanted to
discuss
which was that now that we know after
like this critical probability there
exists a giant
can we say something about the relative
size of it now we want to like bound the
relative size
and here we had the largest expansion
that i promised you to define later
it's
uh
weaker than the expander so instead of
like assuming that the
e of s and s bar
over the size of s is like bounded for
every set i only assume it to be true
for sets s that are like larger than
some epsilon n
why do i need this kind of assumption is
because in many of the random graphs
after i like draw edges there are many
small like components but i don't care
about them as long as like they're
less than epsilon
and you don't have to like if you want
to like know the exact definition of
large expanders that are converging uh
we have it but it's uh
generally we don't need the maximum the
bound on the maximum degree that like
the previous result had
and it can be true as long as the
average degree is bound
there's some
way to equivalently define this in terms
of
so it's interesting because in in cs the
complexities theories have this notion
of
if you talk about the trigger constant
of course sugar constant is relevant to
this five function and then there is a
relation between our spectral gap and
sugar constant so i think there could be
something analogous is there a constant
if you only include
probability
yeah that's what i'm saying so subject
to this as being an epsilon times n if i
don't have it the original definition of
this expand the uh this phi function
is indeed the one version of trigger
constant constant and square and another
two are related one another but if i
impose the large because i don't know
that there could be something of that
kind
it seems like if you could relax the
usual
provenance for example
[Music]
if you go back to the original whatever
whoever proved it
constant relationship if you go through
it and perhaps
[Music]
this sp launch will be played into the
spectral gap i guess
i don't know man
i can tell you is more sensitive thing
that you look at
at the top
and
which is sort of
this unbalanced
let's do a slide
okay so this is definitely a good
question too i understand it better the
license expanded right
so our goal is to like look at the
relative number of nodes in the largest
component of g and p
but to compute that we are like going to
sandwiches between two
different variables but i can describe
it with the local limits what are those
two variables the upper one is kind of
easy to see
instead of looking at the largest
component i only look at the components
that have size larger than some constant
k
and of course any node that has
component larger than size k then it's
also in the largest component as well if
the largest component is linear
because i'm in the super critical case
it's fine
but the lower bond is like using that
sprinkling technique that i talked about
is now instead of looking at
percolation probably p i decrease the
probability with some epsilon and again
i look at the components that
of the nodes that are in a component of
size larger than k in this g of p minus
epsilon
and
sprinkling would now help me to say that
like after i put this epsilon like
probability back all of them would like
merge into a giant component
so everything that appeared here in the
almost everything that appeared here in
the component of larger than size k
would appear in the largest component in
gfp
and
now like
after having like these two different
bonds how
the local limit is actually helping me
to
say something about like
the lower one and the upper one
let's define zeta k of p as the
probability that the
root of the limit is in a component of
size
larger than k
then we can say that like the upper
bound is
is actually a local
property because it only depends on
k neighborhoods then it de
converges to zeta kfp and the lower bond
similarly converges to zero k of p minus
epsilon
now to like complete the proof
i need two more things first is kind of
the first part is kind of easy is that
like if i as i increase k here i go to
infinity so the zeta k of p would like
go to zeta p which was
the connected component of o is like
infinity
so that's the first part but then like
the first the upper bomb would converge
to zeta p and the lower one would
converse to the top p minus epsilon so i
need some kind of continuity between
in zeta as as a function of p to like
finish the proof about the
relative size of the giant and that's
circular that's been proved
um for the like sequence of expanders
that you consider in the theorem
then zeta is continuous it's
equivalently the saying that like the
limit is ergodic
and this was before proof for
deterministic sequence of extenders uh
by starker
i have a stupid question if they have
such a convergence
what
not only the linking
type of saying but then yeah and
directed person is
so we actually don't know how to
sprinkle in the directive version we use
coupling bounds yeah
[Music]
there are two steps in the book first
part is coupling
the director to the undirected like the
informal way if i look at the art
component of a note it's almost like
looking at the
undirected version of the components
and this would like give me like a way
to like characterize the graph
especially
behind below the critical threshold but
this is still like not enough to say
something about this strongly connected
component because i will like
have loops after
i go a little further and a strongly
connected component is in a sense a
global property because if i change the
status of the edge far apart i can
change the status of the like the size
of the largest strongly contact
component by a lot
and for
the sscb
the general idea is to
first lower bond the
expected value of the second moment of
the strongly connected component and
then bound the variance and for bounding
the variance we have to like
do kind of a
delicate like
analysis of influence of every age
to like
then use aphromis strain type
inequalities and bound the second moment
so like as taken as if my attack i'm
very i think i'm
i'm going to like finish a lot sooner
than i was supposed to i guess it's
better everybody can go to the team
yeah
much too
much
so can you tell us a little bit
can you
what is
[Music]
no but you know it so tell us
is that um
let's say even if i'm not looking at
there's a percolation i have just a
lattice and like every
point is later on either zero or one
then i have some function f over the
lattice and the idea is that
to bound
the
the difference in this function s
answer like if one of those look like
this one have already changed so like
that's like the influence but so like
in the
directive like uh percolation i'm
looking at a strongly connected
component let's say i have a cycle
like a directed cycle but only one of
the edges have been like removed if i
add back that
edge then like the size of the astronomy
kind of grows from one to end so that
that edge has like a huge influence
but what it really
what we really show is that like when we
have an expander with high probability
every edge has a small influence
it can be true that like in one hk
scenario like one edge can change the
size of the strong definition 500 by n
but
generally it's just like some epsilon
can i ask
if i
just to ignore all these special people
just look at each
the
impact of uh over changing one edge
sounds like i have actual h edge
exposure to here therefore i might be
able to apply
in a classical sense why why can't i do
that here why should i use this special
form this
fernstein bound
[Music]
but like still like in our example there
is a chance that sometimes one edge has
the influence of like changing the
strongly connected component by
excellent
question for yeah so in probabilities
here when you want to bounce
[Music]
yes okay it turns out that
any kind of calculation
the derivative of a function
much
right yes yes and these variants found
can be in turn
estimated by looking how much a single
edge influences
the value
and all these fancy names are sort of
techniques people have
developed around them yeah so in
classical asymmetry
you usually have a uniform bound
and it is the worst case in some sense i
have to someone yes
but in this afternoon
you can pin down yeah these guys have a
very
tough uh
wrong pack
straight
some of the guys are tamed but then you
can combine them together
you're right there's sort of three steps
if you're really lucky
you
yes
you have the probability one bounded
differences yeah okay then you can
produce a zuma right okay
now you have a more a little bit more
complicated
actually some edges even for the giant
if you're unlucky you could have one
that splits it into two yeah so there's
no bounded so you can't do a zoomer huff
tank nobody bounds the concentration of
the giant using azuma right so you can't
find
and what you want to show
if you use this general technique
is that now
while there could be edges which really
change your thing by a lot
sort of if you take expectations and you
combine the influences of these guys
it's not so bad
in some sense the sprinkle the edges are
crucial in your
merging giant component together to me
they are very very impactful but some of
the guys who are born already before
sprinkling
they do not influence too much i guess
because they are not a cut in some sense
so that's how i digest your efforts time
balance type of thing
well like i think that in the directed
version
sprinkling would not work yes
yeah because i don't have like even i
can't even say i have um
many strongly kind of companies outside
skate
maybe in the limit i have a tree and
it's been hard like to say
that they're strongly connected
component
what does that mean like let's say i
have a configuration model that limited
the scene what is this strong kind of
component
setting because sprinkling is such a
powerful and useful
we couldn't figure that out yeah we
don't know answer yet i think there are
clever guys and girls here
yeah right yeah you don't you don't know
the
equivalent of sprinkling for the
directed version it has been around six
years and now maybe time to develop
something
similar
yeah yeah right so far yeah we have we
had to use like this like marion's fun
and that's not helpful if you introduce
correlation now in the graph so like if
instead of like sir it will be
deterministic or like constant recovery
and if i have a gram and recovery time i
can't use the same method and that
doesn't
succumb then the fact that you go indeed
and start from directed and then you
have to project into the undirected gaze
and then you have to
reinterpret the director case right
in one of your steps right that's like
when yeah that's like for saying
just
yes
right you have to deal with the
defendants but we should have high
probability they're almost independent
so f1 stein has i mean the phonics over
this
one of them just involves
so i've started speaking some diets or
somewhere two or three and that involves
pros and cons l1 version of
distinguished enters efforts time
and the combination which
happens to work here there's effects
the theorem is a very
system is still about independent so
parts of a minsky is just about
independent like the verb
another theoretical question is where
why do you miss fkg
are you teasing you so much sorry
so like i look at the um
everywhere on the right hand side i'm
looking at each vertex and looking at a
strongly connected component
so
if i sum them up for every vertex in
this strongly connected component
everybody has like
multiply like
the number of the times that i have like
seen scc of x is equal to ssc of x so
like i get the
uh second moment of all the strongly
connected components of different sites
and um
now to bound the expected size of the
like
so now now if i look at the expected
size of the both sides
i um
i actually i actually liking that i
really need to like write it down and
accurately say let's like do it
afterwards
and when you want to do that you want to
eventually bounce the probability that
there is a path from x
so you want to you now have sort of the
you want to correlate so you want to
have sort of the size of the entry and
the output
so if there's t two objects which are
now interacting but by fkg
it's bounded by the product of the
corresponding probability and those by
our company were actually
just independent population yeah and
eventually if you go into this bone it
makes out your side of peace creates
slip here yeah yeah that's all right
right but eventually you just want to
drag because if you want to jump
extremely productive components you
start to get into action
because of this inequality
thanks
she
the general takeaway just saturday the
critical probability and the size of the
giant converges to its limits you can
give an algorithmic way to estimate the
limit
and the director cascade the directed
effect percolation is also a convergent
and has a bowtie structure
and like the
maybe a main takeaway for me was that
the graph limit is enabling us to
connect a discrete ball
to the continuous word like using the
ergodic theory even like in the limit
like say something about
the discrete finite like graphs that we
have can we have like more application
of that like
in statistics and algorithms or like
other
maybe games even on graphs
to say something about
exactly thank you again for your
attention another question if this
academic study people come
come to you with their data structure
and they might be uh interested in this
uh zeta of
zeta value that it is indeed the modal
defendant with either limit mu right
c is indeed depending on on the
distribution
mu right and the limit yeah
and perhaps you can pretty much sell
them right yeah i think they didn't need
their algorithm
yeah i mentioned
these low costs
yeah with the local samples you can
create this uh
and then